bonsoir nadine fuchs vice merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit un prêt de 34000 car au monde
24 heures en allemagne c'est un triste
record qui n'avait pas été atteint
depuis décembre 2020 comment l'expliquez
tout simplement
alors je le pense il y a eu une certaine
insouciance ces derniers temps je pense
aussi que certaines personnes ne sont
pas encore vaccinés alors qu'elle
devrait l'être et en plus
les personnes qui ont été vaccinées très
précocement parce qu'elle était à risque
l'ont été au mois de janvier février
mars
2021 et il est temps maintenant de leur
faire un rappel parce que leur taux
d'anticorps diminué ils peuvent de
nouveau contracté la maladie parliez à
l'instant
d'insouciance c'est ce que vous voyez
vous en ce moment dans l'est dans les
rues berlin en allemagne les gens qui
ont repris leur vie d'avant
alors c'est sûr que avec la reprise
depuis l'été une vie à peu près normale
on est les personnes ont tendance à
oublier les gestes barrières et puis
certains refusent absolument d'une part
la vaccination et d'autre part les
protections par masque et c'est un
problème de santé publique en fait alors
aujourd'hui en allemagne presque 67 % de
la population est vaccinée vous nous
parliez à l'instant de ceux qui
n'étaient pas encore
comment vous l'expliquez justement qu'il
reste autant de personnes en allemagne à
vacciner
mais ce ne sont pas des rays des raisons
logiques c'est pour ça qu'elles sont
très difficiles à combattre dans mon
cabinet la grande majorité des patients
sont vaccinés mais il y en a certains
que je n'arrive pas à convaincre parce
que leurs craintes ne sont pas
logiquement fondé quand ce sont des
raisons irrationnel il est très
difficile de lutter contre cela c'est
pour ça que je trouve que la france ça
prend une très bonne mesure en obligeant
par exemple les personnels soignants les
gens qui travaillent dans les ehpad à se
vacciner je trouve que c'est
c'est la voix de la raison alors en
europe en les plus fragiles sont en ce
moment a appelé à se faire injecter une
troisième dose la troisième dose comment
elle est accueillie en allemagne
alors la troisième dose est bien
accueilli parce que ça touche une
population qui étaient déjà vaccinées or
certains se disent je n'aurais jamais
cru qu'il ait fallu une troisième dose
mais enfin ça ça n'est pas un gros
problème le problème c'est d'arriver à
are vacciner toutes ces personnes-là
suffisamment vite or les centres de
vaccination ce qui existait on était
fermé depuis le 30 septembre il en reste
encore quelques-uns
chaque land en garde quelques-uns mais
il y en a beaucoup moins qu'avant et
donc la vaccination repose maintenant
uniquement sur les épaules des médecins
traitants et puis aussi sur un certain
nombre de groupes mobiles de médecins
qui vont vacciner et s'implanter
provisoirement dans des services
hospitaliers alors l'allemagne est
actuellement en phase de transition
politique
est-ce que ça aussi ça pourrait être un
événement qui pourrait expliquer
justement l'augmentation des cas dans le
pays
oui il faut bien savoir que les
décisions en ce qui concerne la
politique de santé ce sont des décisions
qui sont prises au niveau de chaque état
et non pas au niveau
fédéral mais comme vous venez de le dire
il va y avoir une réunion pendant entre
tous les les
emmys la santé des laines et là ça va
aboutir dans un consensus à une décision
commune mais sinon la lutte contre la
pandémie c'est chaque lundi qu'il
organise concrètement alors justement
les ministres de la santé du
gouvernement fédéral et des régions
allemandes vont se réunir 1 se sont déjà
réunis aujourd'hui et vont se réunir
demain avec de possibles nouvelles
mesures de restriction
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça pour pour
l'allemagne les nouvelles mesures de
restriction peut être à venir
écouter le taux d'incidence parle pour
lui-même dans le bade wurtemberg il est
actuellement 173 vous avez cités vous
même des länder où les taux est bien
plus élevé comme la saxo par exemple les
rep aviaire et même à des taux
d'incidence de 234 je compare avec la
france en ce moment on est autour de 70
en france donc il faut réagir mais je
fais confiance aux autorités allemandes
elles vont réagir
comme la france a surréagi au moment où
la situation était en france difficile
il ya quelques mois merci beaucoup
nadine fuchs weiss d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir sur arte france rappelle et que
vous êtes médecin agréé de l'ambassade
de france à berlin merci beaucoup